y
[Música]
las tropas de moscú avanzan en el este
ucraniano controlando cada vez más
territorios severodonezk está bajo
bombardeos constantes y los pro rusos
afirman que ya se tomaron al imán aunque
el ministerio de defensa ucraniano dice
que allí todavía resiste en algunos
distritos
vuelven las protestas estudiantiles a
chile los manifestantes le exigen al
gobierno de gabriel boric subsidios
alimentarios y fondos para mejorar las
estructuras de las escuelas públicas los
carabineros repelieron las marchas con
cañones de agua
el festival de cine de cannes otorgó el
primer premio de este año en la sección
una cierta mirada el ganador fue el
filme francés le piten mañana se
entregará la palma de oro más detalles
desde la riviera francesa en minutos
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
los saluda maría clara calle y es un
placer estar con ustedes iniciamos en
ucrania las tropas rusas han logrado el
mayor avance en semanas y cada vez
golpean más fuerte a las ciudades que
siguen en pie en la región del donbass
los militares de moscú tienen a la urbe
de severodonezk rodeada y según el
alcalde al menos un 60% de los edificios
residenciales están destruidos y 1500
personas han muerto desde el inicio de
la guerra cerca de 13.000 habitantes
permanecen dentro de esta ciudad una de
las pocas de la provincia de lugansk que
no ha caído más al oeste los rusos están
a punto de tomarse la urbe ferroviaria
del imán los prorrusos aseguran que ya
está totalmente bajo su poder e
inicialmente un portavoz de la
presidencia ucraniana afirmó lo mismo
pero luego el ministerio de defensa
sostuvo que hay algunos distritos que
resisten en dirección al imán los
defensores ucranianos están
contrarrestando los intentos del enemigo
de empujar a nuestras tropas desde las
partes noroeste y sureste del imán y
presionar un avance sobre slovenská el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr se y
sostuvo este viernes que cerca de 22
millones de toneladas de granos están
represadas porque los rusos bloquean el
comercio marítimo del país y los efectos
se sienten en otras naciones como egipto
que importa por ejemplo la mitad de los
cereales desde el mar negro ante los
estragos los agricultores egipcios
intentan reforzar el autoabastecimiento
la historia la tiene rafael pérez
egipto siente las consecuencias de la
guerra en ucrania el país que adquiere
cerca de 9 millones de toneladas de
trigo al año y afectada alrededor de la
mitad de sus importaciones del cereal
proveniente del mar negro donde rusia
mantiene un bloqueo como parte de su
invasión allí actualmente cuenta con
unas 300.000 toneladas paradas como un
futuro incierto ante esta escasez el
gobierno egipcio decidió potenciar la
siembra de sus agricultores locales este
año estamos almacenando grandes
cantidades en silos este año
especialmente a veces trabajamos hasta
la medianoche y algunos camiones se
quedan toda la noche
la cosecha durará hasta julio hasta el
momento el gobierno egipcio ha adquirido
unas 3 millones de toneladas de la
siembra local pero a pesar del
descontento por los bajos precios que
paga el cairo comparado con el valor
internacional los productores ven con
buenos ojos el intercambio interno por
la rapidez del pago pero esto es lo que
el gobierno puede ofrecer que podemos
hacer intentamos ayudar al gobierno
organismos internacionales han advertido
sobre el peligro de una crisis
alimentaria en las más pobres países
occidentales acusan a moscú de utilizar
el hambre y el grano como arma de guerra
para entre otros objetivos aumentar los
precios mundiales y provocar la
relajación de las sanciones impuestas
contra su economía los obispos católicos
de italia acordaron un informe sobre los
abusos sexuales que cometieron los
clérigos del país en los últimos dos
años mientras que los casos del 2000 al
2021 sólo tendrán un análisis según
informó el cardenal mateo zuppi los
grupos de víctimas expresaron su
frustración pues pedían una
investigación independiente similar a la
de francia y alemania antes conversamos
con francesco zanardi fundador de red la
bús o la asociación italiana de víctimas
de sacerdotes pedófilos desde savona nos
explicó cuál es la magnitud de la
problemática en el país
los datos italianos son más bien graves
sólo ahora sin la comisión de
investigación los datos que nosotros
hemos recolectado sobre el territorio
italiano son los siguientes frecuentes
actualmente en italia décadas existentes
tenemos 164 sacerdotes actualmente
investigados que no han alcanzado el
tercer grado de juicio mientras que
tenemos 162 que sí han alcanzado el
tercer grado de juicio por lo tanto han
sido condenados y tienen sentencia firme
o esto
en definitiva tenemos 30 obispos con
casos conocidos
161 nuevos señalamientos y 471 casos
impunes es decir casos que nunca
llegaron ante la justicia civil por
estar prescritos y ni siquiera llegaron
a la iglesia debido a que las víctimas
no tienen confianza en la iglesia o en
las instancias para denunciar los de la
justicia civil en cuanto prescrito y no
formalmente malla debate la banquera el
potencial de víctimas que hemos
calculado en italia sobre la base de las
comisiones de investigación de los datos
recolectados en todo el mundo supera el
millón de víctimas de levy que habíamos
calculado en italia sub la base del de
comisión en ingesta de edad de mersin
ducto el mundo es figura y las millones
de víctimas
en houston eeuu protestaron a las
afueras de la convención de la
asociación nacional del rifle cerca de
500 personas llevaban fotografías de los
19 niños y las dos maestras que murieron
en el tiroteo en la escuela de ubal de
esta semana
el debate que reavivó esta matanza sobre
la regulación de los rifles la
organización armamentística más grande
del país realiza su cumbre este viernes
y sábado otra de las discusiones es lo
mucho que tardó la policía para
intervenir en el tiroteo casi veinte
oficiales estuvieron en un pasillo
durante 45 minutos esperando a un equipo
táctico hoy el departamento policial de
texas reconoció que la decisión fue
equivocada
no fue una decisión equivocada y punto
no hay excusa para eso pero de nuevo yo
no estaba allí sólo te digo por lo que
sabemos creemos que debería haber habido
una entrada tan pronto como se pudiera
cuando hay un tirador activo las reglas
cambian ya no es una barricada no tienes
tiempo no te preocupas por los
perímetros exteriores
los estudiantes chilenos volvieron a
salir a las calles de santiago para
exigirle al gobierno educación pública
gratuita y de calidad
concretamente le piden al ejecutivo de
gabriel boric que del presupuesto del
país asigne subsidios alimentarios y
fondos para mejorar las estructuras de
las escuelas públicas los carabineros
respondieron a las marchas con camiones
de cañones de agua especialmente cuando
un bus fue incendiado desde santiago
nuestra corresponsal patricia luna nos
amplía
a estas horas las calles de santiago
vuelven a recuperar un poco la
normalidad después de que el tránsito
haya sido interrumpido en la mañana de
varios puntos de la alameda la avenida
que ven al fondo y que atraviesa una
gran parte de santiago esto por una
nueva manifestación de estudiantes
convocado por la organización mucha báez
en la que se ha convocado a unos 200 300
estudiantes que han atravesado la
alameda en varios puntos de la capital
para demandar una educación de calidad
gratuita no sexista y por ejemplo un
incremento en la beca de alimentación
que también sufre las consecuencias de
la ola inflacionaria que se vive en el
país y en el que el dinero que se
estableció hace unos años no rinde de la
misma forma como ahora alegan los
estudiantes ha habido incidentes
violentos como la quema de un bus
enfrentamientos como la policía con este
sería el tercer bus que se quema en esta
semana en distintas manifestaciones
también de institutos reconocidos y
prestigiosos en el país ante quejas de
en la situación en la que se encuentra
la infraestructura del sistema educativo
en chile una demanda por una educación
de calidad que se pone de manifiesto
que es ahora el presidente del país y
que fue en otro momento un líder
estudiantil y gabriel boric que se le
pide que atienda las necesidades
urgentes del sistema educativo en chile
en colombiano se votará a la primera
vuelta de las presidenciales este
domingo y la economía ha sido una de las
preocupaciones constantes el 40 por
ciento de los colombianos vive bajo el
umbral de pobreza los detalles con
daniela blandón y benjamin de mar
fue el epicentro del comercio de
esclavos y uno de los puertos más
importantes para los españoles durante
la conquista siglos después la joya
turística de colombia cartagena es uno
de los motores económicos y el lugar
seguro para la inversión en un país tan
rico en recursos como desigual héctor
trujillo es miembro de la élite de
antaño y fue gerente regional de la
asociación nacional de empresarios y el
poder empresarial está en manos de
empresas extranjeras esta empresa están
direccionadas tanto en su parte
económica como en su parte política
desde el centro de colombia para él en
plena campaña electoral la política para
los empresarios tradicionalmente de
derecha pasa a un segundo plano si de
dinero se trata pero grandes
conglomerados con tal de quedarse pactan
con crecer
y la clase media de la que estar
sufriendo y el empresario intermedio
para ser testigos de esa creciente
inversión basta con visitar las viejas
casonas de la perla del caribe hoy
convertidas en hostales hoteles boutique
y lujosos restaurantes
ya dis martínez pasa la mayor parte de
sus días en getsemaní
el otrora sector más pobre de la
cartagena amurallada hoy protagonista
del boom turístico
según ella los recursos que van y vienen
no los llegan a beneficiar a todos la
riqueza como tal
no se ve reflejada de 100% la mayoría de
la gente de barrio las mamás se
constituye porque no consiguen un empleo
porque no hay una capacitación porque
hay veces que tanto quieren trabajar
quieren digamos que salir adelante para
unai oportunidades su verdadera realidad
como la de muchos otros miles de
cartageneros al servicio de la industria
y del turismo está en la periferia unas
80 mil personas habitan en este barrio
en donde la pobreza y la abstención
electoral van de la mano al área ya
desconfía en que con su voto contribuirá
a que la situación algún día cambie su
tía hair opina lo contrario la gente por
aquí casi la mayoría de la gente no vota
porque los políticos no hacen nada por
este barrio entonces a veces la gente le
da miedo
según el banco mundial colombia es el
segundo país más desigual de américa
latina después de brasil como bien lo
prueba el diario vivir en 2 cartagenas
reflejo de dos colombias distintas una
con un desarrollo a todo vapor y otro
que siente que jamás saldrá de la
pobreza ya hay un primer ganador del
festival de cine de cannes el filme
francés él le pide de lisa coca y román
jered ganó la sección una cierta mirada
este es el segundo galardón en
importancia del certamen después de la
famosa palma de oro otra de las
novedades de la jornada de khan es que
un joven saltó a la alfombra roja con un
letrero en el que pedía que se
reconociera la matanza en contra del
pueblo a sara en afganistán y que ha
sido perseguido por los talibanes y el
estado islámico el hecho ocurrió cuando
la actriz michelle williams llegaba al
estreno de la comedia dramática zouinat
desde la riviera francesa más detalles
del festival con maría carolina piña
de nuestra cadena hermana face la
competencia en cannes se convirtió en
maratón cinematográfico con cintas
filmadas en tahití corea del sur y una
historia avenida de bélgica
[Música]
el director catalán albert serra está
por primera vez en la historia en la
competencia con paz y ficción una
extraña excursión a la polinesia
francesa
en paz y fiction serra muestra un
paraíso pero de corrupción administrado
por un diplomático francés
magistralmente interpretado por benoit
magimel aquí se tocan en filigrana temas
candentes como la colonización o los
tristeza ensayos nucleares que francia
hizo en polinesia en los años 60 y 70
[Música]
el maestro japonés ha premiado con la
palma de oro en 2018 hirokazu kore-eda
vuelve a la competencia de cannes con
broker una cinta filmada en corea del
sur kuchar más un progreso
cómo
y contento
en esta película kore eda vuelve a
explorar el concepto de familia pero a
través del prisma de los niños
abandonados la cinta comienza con una
joven madre que abandona a su recién
nacido y que luego teje lazos con dos
hombres que se dedican al tráfico de
niños robados
[Música]
el prodigio del cine belga lucas don
estremeció a la clase con su segundo
largometraje close a sus 31 años don
presentó esta película basada en su
juventud sobre la amistad efusiva entre
dos chicos
[Música]
y también sobre mí
si te vas
leo y remis son inseparables cuando
estos dos chicos comienzan el
bachillerato tienen que enfrentar
preguntas indiscretas y humillaciones
leo decide entonces separarse lo que es
insoportable para su amigo klaus es una
cinta brillante e impecable que causó
lágrimas y mucha emoción quizás el
ingrediente del mejor cine
[Música]
pero los compañeros
así llegamos al final de las noticias en
france 24 los invitamos a que sigan
conectados con nosotros
[Música]